have two more please
there is a way out of this and it starts
with queuing up
to get a vaccine you can now just turn
up in bolton
right now it's the indian variant that
obviously brought the cases quite high
and
in bolton um and it's just a matter of
obviously we don't want anything else
causing it it's worrying that these
cases are going up
but i don't think there's any going back
now i think which is
that i personally think it's the right
thing to do let's get things up and get
the country going again but
it's imperative that we all get this
done it's really mentally challenging
for me i've been really struggling
during the lockdown
but coming back again it's really sad
pete watches the urban flow of the
vaccine q
from his driveway opposite the indian
version that's only just come out and
i mean we had the south african one
prior to that
so i i don't know i don't know the the
only
answer i can see is more of this you
know to wake everybody up
they're having more testing too
international travel is one of the
reasons
why the variants are here accelerating
the infection rates they're doing
everything they can to try and disrupt
the direction of that data
but with indoor hospitality about to
reopen and even
cautious hugging allowed from next
monday the idea of
local restrictions here is again under
discussion
but as it stands bolton and the other uk
hot spots
will follow the national easing of
restrictions
next week our schools are asking us
about face coverings in schools and a
number of schools are
are keen to continue with that and we
would very much support that
and we're also advising
our care homes particularly in that area
of the town
to to be cautious about extending the
numbers of visitors
for the time being the authorities need
everyone's help especially with the
muslim celebration of eid approaching
there has been so many needs about
having the vaccine during ramadan does
it break your fast and
same with testing um you know putting
something at the back of your throat
does that invalidate the fast
so there's the i would say there's a
large amount of people that still quite
haven't had the vaccine yet and the risk
is that if we meet for eid
and we pass it on to our parents and
grandparents then it's going to get out
of hand again
hospital admissions are still far below
the peaks of this pandemic
which shows the vaccine is working but
the lesson of the last year
is that things change and this virus
doesn't give up
tom parmenter sky news bolton